this is the stocked escaped from Liam's
Obsession Kate seeks refuge in her
grandpa's Mansion strange occurrences
raised question about Liam's presence or
another figure unraveling mysterious
letters Kate embarks on a journey
seeking
peace I had to break up with Liam and I
hope he takes it well I'm going to guess
by the nature of this game that it did
not go well just going to just going to
guess that that's a weird
[Music]
all right God fing cut that
out you got to cut that
out what do you mean the videos
up but
look I'm I'm not an expert on how time
works but if you're getting this message
then that means that you got it while
you were editing and it's at the very
beginning of the video and so if you're
only getting this message by watching
this afterwards then who is putting you
who uh here and
what oh
all right whatever I'll never live that
down
oh oh SM my stomach oh okay all right
then there's something about hands in
this something about hands all right but
I'm this is a lovely
place can I just say that I I totally
didn't even acknowledge it because it's
so often you play these horror games and
it's all the same recycled assets and I
don't know if it's just another asset
that someone made but this is lovely
it's a bit
too sterile but I do like the wood
accents and the darker colors are nice I
just feel like the little
two clean lines but still it's very
nice God who put the base in this
refrigerator anyway so is this what what
I just eat chickpeas is that what I do
drink a bottle of ketchup that's got to
be some Nutri
drink some sink oh that's dirty oh
oh there you go did that not turn
on ah oh organic food great plop it in
there I love Dy more I actually do
unironically who would be knocking on my
I didn't hear a knock oh I called it
someone's not I'll just leave this
on
coming I'll be right
there who's there hey honey can I come
in Liam I told you it's over so no you
can't come in come on you can't just
leave me like that I love you more than
anything it's over Liam just go home
open the door Kate no I'm not opening
the door I don't love you anymore Liam
you will be mine again soon it's that's
not
good yeah it's not
good food should be ready now yeah it
should
be I don't like
that I don't like that I don't like what
whoa that's funky there's some aesthetic
choices here
hello Yum Yum Yum right out of the pan I
actually just kind of yeah I guess I did
a bath to calm myself down a bit would
be great there's just too many
windows I mean great to have all that
you know access
but a lot of
Windows oh
well either my home is above an empty
void of
nothingness
or I'm up
high is this a condo in a
city okay there doesn't seem to be any
way that someone would be able to just
peruse in why can't I see better through
the
glass strange well I'm
uncomfortable let me take a
bath let me just there's this is this
this this is this is a
problem this is I this is clearly an
issue all right whatever no curtains no
nothing I don't think that counts as
curtain does it even lock okay you know
this is the exhibitionist
apartment oh
no
oh
no oh
no oh so many windows I can't even tell
what's open or
closed
oh oh
boy lexian put some more musical stings
in
there let me give you another
one how about one
more one more more give me another
chance please I'll treat you well and do
anything you want I promise ignore the
window this is the only way just one
chance is all I ask that can't be too
much can it smooches and hugs smooches
and hugs rocks through the window Liam
no no no I got to leave before he does
something worse yeah that's actually a
very sensible idea also where did he
throw this
from where the hell did he throw
damn Li Liam that's a that's a heavy ass
Rock little did I know I was dating a
champion shot putter I am out of here
definitely I should bring some water
with me
before always got to remember to say
hydrated you right what oh my God oh my
[Music]
God
huh
huh I don't think I need any
water oh I see you
peekabo
I made it did I make it all right well
that was awful and terrifying and I
hated
it
hello I feel like this is distracted
driving that I should be looking
like at the broad F in Drive hello
grandpa I need your
help hey Kate what's what's going on
Liam broke into my apartment and chased
me I barely got away and now I'm in my
car with nowhere to go that's horrible
are you okay did he hurt you or
something no I got away before he could
do something but I'm terrified he'll
find me okay I assume you're looking for
a place to stay for a
while yes I Own a Mansion about an
hour's drive from your city it should be
empty for a couple weeks I feel like
this would have come up in conversation
Grandpa great thanks Grandpa can I go
there right now to this mansion that I'm
just learning about
yeah I'll send you the address and the
key to the mansion is in the basement
there's a
ghost no problem I hope all go goes well
and don't hesitate to call me again
we're just not going to comment on The
Ghost and also was I driving I wasn't
then why is it in
Drive put your parking brake
on
freck Mark Zuckerberg you get out of
here all right yeah
that's
okay
what
what that was a close call yeah lock
your door you were sitting in the
parking
lot where finally broken free from that
toxic
relationship I guess it's responsible
not to drive and
call but it's in an emergency at least
lock your
door oh no did Liam manage to to follow
me I'm getting too paranoid now of
course it's not him probably just a
neighbor all right here's a here's a tip
this isn't universally helpful obviously
but know where your local fire
department or police station is know
where it is so that even if you don't
have your phone you can get to it then
go there not an abandoned mansion in the
middle of the woods an hour out of the
city go to the hospital even if you
don't need medical attention know your
Landmark location everyone should know
where the hospital is nearest them
period
because anyway yeah you should know
where the fire fire station is police
station and Hospital nearest to you are
and you should have them memorized so
that you can go there even if you don't
have a
car or go to your grandpa's mansion that
you had never heard of before Grandpa
said the key was in the
basement I don't remember grandpa saying
that but then maybe I was distracted by
the
ghost all right I'll just that's a good
place to keep a
key no one had everything to check
there definitely wouldn't be a perfect
way for intruders to break
in
oh good it's
open
God oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah at
least this feels familiar you know I
don't feel as scared here for some is
that a
ghost the jonos
brothers all right what is why do I what
is what is the ghost I see you
ghost see you go where are you I'm like
chica oh oh oh there it is it's a
reflection on my phone I have a phone
the flashlight is not a flashlight it's
my phone it's a
phone that's not a
key that's a syringe that's a manual
drill that's a kidney Bowl those are
medical scissors that's more concerning
that's infinitely more concerning the
chains hook and handcuffs are infinitely
more
concerning dare I look to my left d here
I it's a bigger handcuff another hook
and more hand oh that's for your
neck and there's a
radiator and there's another radiator
and another radiator this oh good hooks
from the
ceiling and a
lamp great more hooks that
Grandpa is that a
coffin
I'm trying not to mind the fact the
light behind me is pulsing about the
same rate as the light in the
game I'm trying not to pay attention to
that it's not synced up or
anything all right anyway uh so grandpa
oh and there's a key sorry I didn't see
it amongst all
the stuff
the hobby equipment and I hope that's a
pole dancing pole that would hurt a bit
and another coffin oh another
coffin
good if you think about it it's the
perfect criminal deterrent cuz they go
in the basement looking for the key and
they see all those stuff and they don't
have an explanation from Grandpa I don't
either
but I trust him I trust Grand
Grandpa if there's one thing I do it's
trust
him
peekaboo wow it's dark in here let's
turn on some lights and find the bedroom
I want to hit bed ASAP yeah
again not the best move to just
immediately go to sleep without seeing
if anybody is stalking you just it's
just you know
Ah that's not
better that's
horrible is
horrible the fact that the matter
is this
horrible toilet paper axe that's
important I won't take that definitely
cuz the second rule is if you're alone
in a random mansion in the middle of
nowhere you definitely don't want a
weapon by your
side who needs
that what a Dy tiny clock actually it's
quite big for a clock but for a
grandfather clock
it's maybe it's symbolic maybe it's
saying that the grandpa is either weird
or short I don't know know which one's
worse
hello
bedroom
freak that chair is a little
funny chairs chair is a little
low you know I wouldn't been surprised
if it was just a letter on this desk
that says like I eat people Written in
Blood also I love my
granddaughter all right where's his
bedroom I am
tired
woo did you think someone misunderstood
the concept of what a radiator was and
they you just buy a bunch of Radiators
don't bother hooking them up to anything
and you just lay them around your house
and it'll bring the warm ghosts in
that's what this feels like hey this is
the darkest room of them
all leave
yeah don't lock
it why would you do
that oh
yawn I'm so tired hope I don't get woken
up in the middle of the
night oh
freck oh never
mind all is
well
why have we not learned our
lesson why have we not learned our
lesson
okay
peekaboo who is
it who is
it is that grandpa's car I don't
know I'm going for
it hello
peekaboo oh that's my
car dearest new resident of this Mansion
I'm previous owner of this mansion and
you are the person I've been looking for
I hope to see you stick around for a
while I'm sure we will get along just
fine I will be watching you kind of joke
is this I can't be bothered to deal with
some stupid teenagers right
now well I better get going to the
convenience store before it gets dark
even though I just woke
up goodbye haunted
house we're
here I is a no store press tab look at
the shopping list
oh I play a game like this before
hi hello please don't turn around in a
Flash oh hi there haven't seen you
around here before you new yes I just
moved in
I did I where do you live I don't feel
comfortable telling you that are you
alone I'm in a hurry sorry I got to
go
a hi are you going to be
terrifying man they really nailed The
Uncanny Valley
look all right I didn't need to talk to
you anyway canned food
uh you I feel like I could have just
remembered
this you soda no no I don't a basket
maybe not a basket oh I need to put it
away
die I see die I see no I don't yes I do
no I don't yes I do I won't get
anything I hate food well I can't click
on
anything guess I'll go home then
nope guess I'll run off and
nope
ah I need to get in a specific ah ah ah
my
favorite can I have nope you all
right all right oh
bye does this milk good just out
here okay sure thing and you got to have
some wine I'll go pay for this
hi a hello beautiful thank you this is
great yes all right the total is 28
thank you for shopping here also I can
tell you're new to the area how long you
staying for I'm not sure yet not too
long I would assume all right have a
good day and near your groceries thanks
you
too oh no that's a new
person
okay
yeah you're right you're right I
shouldn't what do you want I do have
some wishes but I think it's best they
remain unspoken
I hope your aorta explodes be careful
don't let me catch you all alone
again step on a
landmine
please I don't need your warnings
respect my space and stay
away how far away was it this is place
is an hour outside of the city I I don't
think I dawle that
hard oh boy
yep
sure oh
no oh no oh boy yeah let me close myself
in here why is
this oh boy that's bad that's that's
what you don't want to see that's what
you don't want to
see all
right
great
it's good it's
good
oh
boy oh is that blood no it's a
carpet
well oh
boy oh boy I don't know about this gu I
feel like I maybe I should run
but
I don't know what do I do what do I do
do I go do I do I go do I go am I I
don't
know
oh okay dearest new Resident
congratulations on settling in you may
believe this Mansion is your Refuge but
every step you take reveals a deeper
game I'm within you in every Choice
every move There's No Escape From The
Inevitable end
oh is my car gone no it's there I'm okay
this is where I would
drive
[Music]
so well
there you
go you can support that game on Steam by
wishlisting it I will say as much as I
was like these decisions seem
questionable the the game creeped me out
it did I'm not going to lie I was I was
perturbed some of those jump scares they
got me good that was that was downright
startling horrifying even pretty good so
I'd love to see more because definitely
there's some style here
and
I feel like I would make better choices
in some aspects but you know Grandpa uh
has some questionable things going on
anyway thank you so much for watching
let me know what you thought down in the
comments below I'll leave a link to the
game I might as well leave a link to the
game Steam page here in the description
check out more scary games I got a lot
always do always will
maybe maybe and as always I'll see you
in the next
video
bye-bye